JEREMY SILVER: Have
you ever wondered
what happens when you click
Run in Android Studio?
The Gradle build tool
swings into action,
fetching dependencies, compiling
code, and packaging resources.
Experts at Gradle and
Udacity have teamed up
to create "Gradle for
Android and Java,"
a course designed to
help everyday developers
and experts alike
demystify Gradle
and what it can do
for you and your apps.
In this course, you'll learn
the Gradle build language,
create and integrate libraries,
write tests, and create an app
with free and paid versions.
Gradle is a key tool in the
Android developer's tool belt.
And once you learn
the ins and outs,
you'll wonder how you
ever got by without it.
Get started now.
Your users are waiting.
For more information,
visit udacity.com/google.